sollte schützt dann noch ein bisschen
hin und wieder gekittet hier mensch
kummer
das ist der job was sagst du zu deiner
verteidigung dass ihr die ganze scheiße
wieder ausgeblieben
ingo zum verteidigung man coated nicht
in die öffentlichkeit schockiert
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft den exit minecraft exit
über diese bleiben egal ich mache mir
denn die mob voller an weil ich ja
wieder weiter
da ist schon fleißig was am zittern
alter was los mit dem wenigsten lust mit
mir
damit machte er den dafür ein kakadu
harald harry kewell fast nix aber woher
kommt einfach haus explodierte das
kratzt so ich brauche auf jeden fall
noch ein paar level diese letzten herzen
wenn das als miniatur herzen während ich
würde weinen vor glück ist vielleicht
sogar die ganze zeit leben
ich würde mich wieder einer frage wird
finden die auf twitter gestellt oder
miniatur hat
nein ich hab nur crêpes bekommen und
zwar ist diese frage eigentlich ganz
cool was nicht durch youtube in meinem
leben verändert hat
die frage ist was schon oft so mehr oder
weniger teilweise behandelt worden aber
noch nie so dass ich die halt so richtig
beantwortet habe sollte sich hier ein
frosch im hals und zwar würde ich sagen
dass ich dadurch halt bekanntschaften
gemacht habe also ich möchte nicht sagen
freunde weil ich die ganzen leute halten
hat sie noch nie gesehen habe aus ein
paar im echten leben
ich hatte gar kein helm auf alter ich
hätte locker mal sterben können ich habe
einfach kein helm eine rüstung geht
einfach mal so richtig kaputt richtig
crazy ich habe leute kennengelernt ich
habe auch schulisch nachgelassen muss
man einfach so sagen
in der neunten klasse die im schnitt von
1,9 und jetzt dann das nächste zeugnis
ohne scheiß waren 3,4 schnitt das war
mega der absturz das ist in jedem fall
mehr als eine note schlechter weil
einfach durch youtube hab ich mich
komplett auf youtube konzentriert am
anfang und nicht auf schule et cetera
das war echt richtig richtig krass und
sich eigentlich gar nicht so viel
verändert würde ich sagen ich bin immer
noch gleich geblieben eigentlich so von
fahrt vom verhalten her und so ganz
wirklich hat sich eigentlich jetzt nicht
so viel verändern will ich sagen hast du
jemals richtig angst als du irgendein
spiel gespielt hat welches war es am
lesen hat bisher am meisten angst länder
menschlich nahezu gar keine angst es war
irgendwie weiß nicht dass das jetzt
nicht so viel angst fand ich gar nicht
so schlimm weil weise meine zeit so
guckt sich um ein fahrer ist jetzt
länder männer gucken dann ist er auch
ein bisschen doof von der spielengine
das halt nicht irgendwie auf einmal vor
die vor einem baum auftaucht oder so ein
bisschen doof ich muss gleich mal wieder
meinen in vatikanischen entleeren kann
ich mal irgendwer von euch so ein
komisches herbst fallen lassen
da ist mehr drin
hier liegt auch nur herum das ist ein
diamant schwert alles gar nicht hier
ich möchte jetzt wieder alles in erbach
irgendwann der dann in netter geht der
krieg dann einfach alle sachen von mir
aufgesammelt was ist das für ein google
ist nicht mehr geht und wir wissen nicht
und wollen googeln was was was ist wenn
es google nicht bei gelb und wir wissen
es nicht und wollen googeln was mit
google ist wenn ich das für eine dumme
frage wer ins google nicht gibt wieso
willst du denn was google da willst du
diesen begriff auch gar nicht geben
dann würde es wahrscheinlich andere
suchmaschinen geben wenn leute auf diese
idee gekommen wäre bei google weil
einfach die erste dann werden wir halt
yahoo aber als ich jetzt die frage
einfach nur doof wenn es google nicht
gelb dann wird der begriff google auch
gar nicht existieren das ist als
sprachwissenschaftlich ein ganz
interessantes thema diese dieser
ursprung der sprache finde ich ist was
ganz ganz interessant ist worüber ich
auch mein abi wahrscheinlich schreiben
werde hoffentlich ich hoffe dass die
sprache kommen nicht in goethes gedicht
oder so und zwar ist es so dass der cas
zu einem langen vortrag darüber halten
über sprachwissenschaft es gibt einfach
verschiedene teilweise noch 32 es gibt
einfach online aktiver aufsammeln naja
kommt papa meine damen und herren juni
ist ja nicht so
so kann ich jetzt hier nicht einfach dir
dich da rein werfen
das geht sogar kann ja einfach rein
werfen da das sogar verzaubert das sehr
schön braun trotz ziemlich hornig es
gibt ja diese verschiedenen lehrern wie
kinder zum beispiel die sprache erlernt
habe oder wie der sprach ursprung
aussieht und da ist es einfach so dass
es halt verschiedene ursprungs
möglichkeiten gibt es gibt regionale
entfernungen göttlicher ursprung dieses
andere abschnitte den namen vergab ich
habe gerade meine deutsch mal belegen
dass ganz cool
dann haben wir hier unter anderem die
über die aktuell genetischer sprach
ursprung der onto genetischer
spracherwerb die viele genetische sprach
ursprung auf platogo nie dass es die
spracheinstellungen der
menschheitsgeschichte spracherwerb des
kindes also so etwas wie da gibt es
verschiedene theorien die heizen
wirklich so lala theorie war theorie
mama theorieprüfung theorie also das
sind so theorien wieder jetzt wie das
kind halt sprach er ja sag ich mal so
was wie die fußball theorie ist dann
beispielsweise da ist mir schon wieder
zu viel los doch ist beispielsweise
diese ekel sachen also dass man zum
beispiel wenn man sich ekel sagt man
dass man dadurch war die sprache erlernt
du bist scheiße ich sehr stark lässt ich
mal stark beiseite mit der du bist
gib mir doch einfach ein verdammt des
miniatur rc [ __ ] ich will ein
miniatur herd haben mama
hier kommt kein miniaturen l wie mich
das amt ist ich will nicht diese ganzen
scheiß bögen und sogar miniatur also ja
ich denke also wenn es wenn zum beispiel
google nie gegeben hätte dann jetzt noch
nicht diesen begriff wir umfassen das ja
quasi immer wir kategorisieren das wäre
mir zum beispiel sagen ja ich suche mal
im internet dann sagt man automatisch
google dort mal anschaut sucht mal im
internet auch wenn man gar nicht google
benutzt man sagt einfach googlen weil
dieser begriff mittlerweile als sie
eingebürgert ist man man sagt nicht ja
such mal im internet oder im internet da
dachte ich meine das ganz interessante
sache mit mit der sprache und video
entstanden ist und so was alles packt
jetzt einfach mal hier mithin kann
schock die eigentlich sinken
so kann ich mich da so da sind meine
beine viel kürzer so egal ich gehe
wieder weiter hier fahren ich wollte
mich 32 level um das sollte erstmal
drauf zu packen und dann wollte ich mir
eventuell sogar noch mal lena bogen
machen ich hab ja ganz immer noch ein
weil ich wollte auch auf die aber
umsteigen und nicht auf crystal ball
wohl der christopher natürlich auch
seine vorteile
ich denke manchmal 2000 millionenschaden
weil es halt einfach immer dieses
schwarzen herzen ab aber ich hätte nein
halben und man nicht mehr die natur
herzen fragen lieblings manga pokémon
wenn man das als manga bezeichnen kann
und sonst
detektiv conan obwohl ich bei detektiv
conan zugeben muss dass ich da immer
angst hatte vor den doofen großen leuten
die nada als mörder dargestellt wurden
hatte ich echt mal richtig angst vor so
was würdet ihr mitnehmen wenn ihr wisst
dass ihr das haus verlassen müsste zum
beispiel bei einer flut begrenzt mir das
ganze immer auf fünf sachen weil sonst
will ich einfach alles mitnehmen wenn
man weiß dass mir hoch eine sturmflut
kommt dann ist es also dass man das bei
weiß ja was ich auf jeden fall mitnehmen
würde ist mein pc
ich habe schon mal gesagt was man auf
einer einsamen insel mitnimmt aber ja
alles oder halt die dinge plätzen schon
mal gesagt habe wenn jemand sterben
müsste würdest du dann deine eltern oder
dich und deine schwester stirbt was ich
es für eine frage
die lage gibt es schon eure canela das
ist kann man auf dem kanal nach gucken
was haltet ihr von pferdchen
was haltet ihr von den ganzen verbotenen
china das ist mal wieder eine gute frage
das sind so fragen über die man wirklich
reden kann und nicht so ich mag pferde
oder nämlich mal keine pferde so das
sind so themen die fünfklässler dann
stellt das ist einfach weiß nicht also
zurzeit in china
falls ihr nicht was ich davon halten
soll weil ich finde eigentlich die welt
sollte sich mal also ist natürlich
schwer wir haben natürlich als hole ich
hier wieder aus
es ist natürlich immer so du kannst ja
alles mit allem verbinden wir
verschiedene organisationen in unserer
welt da gibt es beispielsweise die wto
es gibt den internationalen
währungsfonds iwf
es gibt sachen die unicef hat als ich
glaube schon
gibt es überhaupt noch greenpeace es
gibt verschiedene gipfel es gibt den g8
gipfels gibt den g20 gipfel
es gibt verschiedene treffpunkte wo man
sich trifft und einfach über
verschiedene dinge
ich sag mal sich unterhält wo eine
lösung kommt dabei nahezu nie raus und
das ist immer so dass man es halt
verschiedene länder immer in so in
diesen organisationen sag ich mal mehr
oder weniger mit drin und man kann quasi
so eine organisation nicht an land sagen
verändert das oder er fliegt raus das
kann man nicht sagen man kann die quasi
nur man kann ihnen nur sagen ja ich lege
euch nagel dies zu verändern denn sonst
würdest du den teddy und die konsequenz
haben die werden allerdings ähnlich
machen
beispiel dafür was fehlt sind beispiele
dafür irak afghanistan ägypten und in
china ist es halt auch so bzw in manchen
anderen ländern das gehalt
ein paar dinge anders geregelt werden
jetzt haben wir zum beispiel die
demokratie war gut geregelt ist durch
steuer als mädchen wodurch dann die
umwelt hier alles viel besser gemacht
wird unsere dies dass straßen gebaut für
dich institutionen wie kindergärten
werden dadurch finanziert das ist super
geregelt oder weidenfeller vor dem buch
und deswegen weiß ich nicht warum mir
das nicht so quasi als die komplette
welt begreift es ist natürlich sehr
schwer weil dort halt andere leute eine
macht sind auch andere ein anderes
grundgesetz sage ich mal herrscht aber
nicht achtet miniatur hat weil das so
komisch rausgeschleudert kam äußerst
kleine miniatur hier komm erstmal darauf
dass zwölf gekostet nicht 30 es sollte
sollte er sollte an breaking 3 und 4 3
und zwei und vier auf drei und vier
erhöhen
3 und 4 3 und 4 die rüstung ist glaube
ich mehr kann ich nicht machen
als wollte ich von meinem kristlbauer
eben die ganzen erfahrungen unternehmen
kkr war schon drauf sollte also 76 level
habe ich so jetzt wollte ich den bogen
nämlich
austauschen zu einem ist hier denn
nirgendwo ein ligapokal tränen meine
damen und herren
liga nein nein habe ich nicht ausgemacht
es wird ja eigentlich nichts nachkommen
oder ich brauche das einfach mal ein
paar
ich möchte mich auf einen liga bogen
wieder umsteigen und den richtig krass
verzaubern hab ich richtig bock auf als
das paar opitz gesehen habe schnell
damit damit schaden macht da reicht
schon ein wenig neidisch dann als solche
ja also das nicht zu themen über die man
halt so gut und lange diskutieren kann
das freut mich dann auch immer wenn
solche themen ankommen killers kamera
und jetzt nicht so was die märkte ferien
ja ich würde sagen die folgen die immer
noch fünf minuten wir lassen das jetzt
erstmal mit den fragen und ich
konzentriere mich gerade ein bisschen
erachte ich jetzt mein legia bogen finde
wenn ich denn überhaupt ein halbes jahr
auch wieder die sache habe ich den
damals denke schwitzen
eigentlich habe ich das gefühl dass ich
in erinnerung aber ich hätte meine damen
und herren sind vergittert gefunden habt
wirklich zum lila bogen menschenskinder
so brächte lederbogen ja im rhein dass
man hier reparieren
könnt ihr nicht reparieren jetzt geht's
an breaking power punch was die
wichtigste sache aber fast gar nichts
drauf bleibt ab 33a oder was hat noch
keine gute idee weil sie nicht
schon krass eigentlich ja das nicht mehr
empfindet die jetzt darauf das ist
eigentlich so mit das wichtigste da kann
ich überhaupt auf dem labor machen
diese molekulare minuten braten können
helfen parat malone eine goldene feder
wollte ich ihn mitnehmen
die ninja der jetzt ein paar sachen die
ich auf jeden fall immer dabei haben
muss euch auf jeden fall nicht big sword
auch nicht regenbogen ich sortiert hat
man so hab ich denn nicht doch ich muss
doch irgendwo kann das denn nicht da
sind fackeln ich immer noch eine goldene
feder mit da kann es egal
so ist es leben noch zwei blöcke hab ich
gleich drei nähe ich noch obsidian dafür
und da habe ich jetzt einfach ab wie
deren zu holen
oder habe ich hier noch vielleicht
irgendwie wenn ich jetzt hier das wäre
natürlich nächstes der fabrik blog ich
setze jetzt einfach mal hier so ein
schild hin
hallo ich bin okay bitte füttern
sollte später noch ein bisschen hin und
wieder gekittet hier mensch kummer da
das ist der job
was sagst du zu deiner verteidigung dass
er die ganze scheiße wieder ausgeblendet
das thema zum verteidigung man coated
nicht in die öffentlichkeit tokio
hallo und damit mehr du besser nein ich
hab dich lieb
stell dich dahin so jetzt ihnen
vielleicht andere leute an ihr vorbei
und sehen oh hallo ich bin schockiert
gefüttert werden u so weiß ich jetzt
noch eben paar sachen müll die
verschwinde aber auch gar nicht nur aber
es cool dass ich dir einfach
reinspringen kann ich brauch nur einen
pfeil
die 68 kommen die ganzen stifter unnötig
so ich setzte die skyteam blöcke wurde
ziehen hin
darauf könnte in dieser das passt gar
nicht das ist ja nicht drei breiter der
doof ich setze jetzt einfach ich jetzt
hier ein spanferkel dafür und hier
so habe ich im redstone reiz denn fakt
so habe ich dann eigentlich sind die
einfachsten sachen wieder okay ich habe
einfach alles müll geschmissen und sport
habe ich zwei stück so dann packe ich
dir jetzt einfach mal drunter packen
haley scheiße drauf packen
man oh da kommt dann kommt sie dahin
ich werde dann also meine rüstung ist
jetzt wer möchte ich eigentlich noch mal
viel schreibt jetzt mal alle ganz viel
in die kommentare was ich also dass er
mir jetzt quasi in die kommentare
schreibt was ich beim eine rüstung noch
alles verbessern soll ich hab die
protection an breaking salter überall
das höchste drauf und vor allem was ich
bei meinem ende giants ort und vor allem
bei dem legia bogen noch verbessern kann
beziehungs verzaubern kann damit ich
natürlich in der einen oder anderen
nächsten folge den einen oder anderen
mitspieler hier penetrant er in den
arsch penetrieren kann solltet ihr mir
das dann einfach schnellstens in die
kommentare schreiben und sonst welche
fragen weil die freunde wir sind am ende
der folge angelangt ich würde sagen es
euch gefallen hat laut doch bitte eine
bewertung da ich werde den nächsten
folgen wenn leute drauf sind versuchen
die anzugreifen wenn ich sterbe ist es
halt so ich hab's sollte dabei drauf
deswegen kann ich eigentlich nicht viel
verlieren
jetzt noch ein paar sachen drin die
müsste ich eventuell noch gleich
einsortieren so viel scheiße einfach
dran
also ich bin mal kurz die sachen raus
die wichtig für mich sind hier sehr 23
oder nicht so gut
die erfahrung damals so alle sachen
holte erstmals die wichtig für mich sind
goldene güter er überhaupt nicht wichtig
da habe ich auch schon serviceteil
unnötigen goldene apfel vielleicht so
den rest cagliari auf wegschmeißen
den rest kann ich eigentlich
wegschmeißen
dann packe ich das jetzt auch heute die
ganze kaka um mich herum hat das ja
alles mal eben in die kisten rein weil
man aber bei barbara bekommen und dann
will ich sagen hat eine bewertung da
wenn es euch gefallen euch immer 15
rotter und schreibt mir das mikrofon
wieder alles gut und tschüss